okay so I wanted to talk a little bit
about the coverage of everything that's
happened in Ferguson and of course you
guys all know what happened at this
point but I do want to bring up one
little thing which I mentioned in the
Ruben report this week which is that
this wasn't about the trial of Darren
Wilson the officer that shot Mike Brown
this was just the grand jury decision
whether this thing was going to go to
trial and I think it's important to say
that because people I think think that
somehow uh Darren Wilson got off that
there was an actual jury trial and he
got off that's not what happened here
and it's important to be clear about
that what happened here is that this
didn't even have enough evidence so to
speak according to the prosecutor to
even get to trial uh so it's important
that we know that so that when you're
talking about it and I think for the
people that are out there that are upset
that are uh the people that are rioting
the people that are Marching etc etc I
think it's important that everyone knows
the facts the people that are upset with
those people and the people that are
back uh backing Darren Wilson I think
need to understand what the facts are so
I think that's just an interesting piece
of the puzzle but what I really want to
talk about here was sort of the media
coverage of it and the social media part
of it and all that because that's the
part that we're all in on we're all in
on it together and as I've been watching
this stuff you know I have uh I have
usually CNN on when I'm watching and
then I'll flip between Fox and MSNBC
just to kind of get balanced that
there's no balance there but just to get
some sort of view of what everybody in
that world is thinking um and it's
really interesting how they all sort of
do it a different way but then also on
social media because I'm on doing the
Twitter thing the whole time and how
everyone you know we all have an opinion
on this and we've talked a lot about uh
on my show how everyone constantly feels
the need to have an opinion on
everything and as an opinion guy I
understand certainly why but I think
there's something really interesting
about sort of the shared experience that
we now all have with this because with
these cable news channels going 24 hours
a day in the 24-hour news cycle that
everybody's always talking about and
then our ability to tweet and put Vines
up immediately if something happens that
you can get video on real quick and
Facebook it or is anyone on Facebook
anymore I don't know uh but all this
stuff that we're all watching this all
unfold together I think is really kind
of fascinating and there's parts of it
that you really feel connected to all of
it and it almost feels empowering like
something's really happening uh that
you're part of while you're just sitting
in your home uh and then there's another
part that it almost feels like slightly
nauseating uh that we're all doing this
all together I'm really curious what
your thoughts are on it so let me know
in the comments right down below